president
and first lady biden
vice president harris and second
gentleman imhoff
peter schumer
speaker
pelosi elder ballard
most of all to
harry's beloved landra
three children and grandchildren
friends
and former staff
it's a great honor to be with you
today to pay tribute
to my friend harry reid
now
to be clear and as chuck mentioned
in his remarks
i suspect harry himself
would not have wanted to sit through
this thing
harry did not like being
the center of attention
it made him a little awkward
he was uncomfortable
when people said too many nice things
about him
but as he looks down on us today
harry is going to have to suck it up
because few people had done more for
this state
and this country
and this driven
brilliant
sometimes irascible
deeply good man from searchlight nevada
i first met harry in 2005 after i'd been
elected to the senate
and harry had been elevated to become
democratic leader
and i was the sole african-american in
the senate at the time
a mixed kid
with a funny name
and given how different our
backgrounds were i did not know
how well harry and i would hit it off
he was older of course
his kids were grown
i didn't know what
kind of music he liked but i figured he
didn't listen to jay-z
on the issues he had a reputation for
being a little more conservative than i
was reflecting the politics
of his western state
so
he invited me to his office for a chat
shortly after i'd been sworn in
there was not a lot of small talk
in fact there was not a lot of talk at
all
he asked me what committee assignments i
wanted
i told him he said
he'd see what he could do
half the time his voice was so soft i
could barely hear what he was saying
afterwards
my senior colleague from illinois dick
durbin asked me how it went
i said
and i don't know
the whole conversation lasted maybe 10
minutes he did not seem particularly
pleased with my
taking up his time
don't worry dick said
if harry didn't like you it would have
only lasted five minutes
that was harry
as has been observed
harry was not a schmoozer
or a backslapper
he did not regale you with long
drawn-out stories and he did not
appreciate long drawn out stories
despite
the years he'd spent in congress
despite
all the power he wielded his reputation
as being the consummate washington
insider what i came to realize was that
harry
always remained something of an outsider
in washington
which makes sense
given
the remarkable path to the senate
that he had taken a path that was at
least as unlikely if not more unlikely
than mine
others have mentioned harry's
extraordinary journey out of searchlight
a tiny desert town an hour
away from just about everywhere
how harry had to hitchhike more than 40
miles each way to henderson
and stay with relatives just to go to
high school
how he put himself through college and
law school moonlighting as a uniform
capital police officer to help cover
tuition and support a young family
fair to say it was not easy
there
must have been times where he felt doubt
about
achieving his dreams
like the time when his car broke down
and he walked into the dean's office to
say that he wasn't sure if he could
afford to finish school
as harry remembered it the dean
looked him up and down and said
mr reed why don't you just quit
that dean did not know harry reid's
character
like others who would later
underestimate the man
hardship
had forged a steal in harry
a fighting spirit that
explained
his success
in the boxing ring despite being
significantly undersized
he liked to talk about his boxing
you know barack
i wasn't a great athlete
i wasn't big and strong like some of the
guys i went up against
i had two things going for me
i could take a punch
and i never gave up
that's about right
that same dogged determination
marked harry reid's political career
he lost his first senate race by just
600 votes
six months later he ran
for mayor of this town and lost in a
landslide
but harry did not give up
he got himself a seat in the house
then the senate
finally became senate majority leader
and
let's face it
he enjoyed every minute of proving
doubters wrong again and again and again
sometimes the people who motivate us the
most
perry would later say
are the ones who believe in us
the least
so yes being tough
being a fighter
was one of harry's singular
characteristics
apparently
once a staffer handed him
some draft remarks in which
he was supposed to refer to himself as a
former boxer
and harry crossed out the word former
he was 70 years old at the time
but there were other aspects to harry's
character that helped
explain his extraordinary achievements
qualities that
at this particular moment
in our history
seem
especially relevant
first and foremost
harry was a pragmatist
at a time when so many americans across
the political spectrum
apply strict purity tests to our
politicians
demanding they toed the line on just
about every issue at a time when
so often compromises
portrayed as weakness
mary had a different view
he didn't believe in high falutin
theories
or rigid ideologies
he thought most people make decisions
based on their life experience based on
the immediate needs of their families
based on their own self-interest no
matter what they may tell themselves
and as a result
harry met people where they were
not where he wanted them to be
and he was willing to cut deals
even with folks he didn't agree with
or particularly like
i heard nancy pelosi say she never heard
harry say anything bad about any of his
colleagues
i don't know about that nancy
but he would work with him
i love nancy but i
[Laughter]
but he would work with them
if that's what it took to move things
forward
in a battle between perfection
and progress
harry always chose progress
that pragmatism made harry adaptable
when he first got to washington harry's
voting record wasn't so different from
those who'd represented his state in the
past
holding traditional positions on issues
like gun rights immigration reproductive
health
but as nevada and the country changed
as harry met
more and more people
from different walks of life and
realized their struggles weren't that
different from
his families had been in searchlight
harry's views on some of these issues
changed as well
he didn't consider that a weakness
he understood that he wasn't always
going to be right about everything
he knew how to listen
and to learn
he was humble enough to admit when he
had to change his mind and grow
and by the way speaking from personal
experience
it helps when you're married to somebody
who's wiser and brighter than you
i know something about that
after harry introduced a bill repealing
birthright citizenship in the 1990s for
example
landra pointed out that her own father
had been a russian immigrant
later harry would say i came to the
realization
that i was way off base
i'm so glad she righted the ship
now of course there are plenty of
politicians who change their positions
just because
they want to get reelected
they've got their fingers out to the
wind
they're interested in clinging to power
for its own sake
but for harry the whole point of holding
office
the whole point of wielding power
was to actually get things done on
behalf
of those
he represented
during his time as leader that is
exactly what he did he got things done
without harry we would not have passed
the recovery act
helping to prevent
another great depression
about harry we wouldn't have saved
people's jobs
help people stay in their homes
without harry we would not have passed
wall street reform reining in some of
the worst abuses of the financial
industry
without harry there would be no
affordable care act
people forget that there were many times
during the debate over health care
reform when it looked like
nothing was going to get passed
but harry
working with nancy pelosi in the house
working with then vice president and now
by
now president my partner
in this fight joe biden
harry refused to give up
maneuvering and applying pressure like
only he could
the deals harry made to get
that law done didn't always look pretty
he got votes
whenever i would object to a change he
wanted to make
whether because
of some policy concerns or worries about
the optics
harry would tell me
with some exasperation in his voice
mr president
you know a lot more than i do about
health care policy okay
and i know the senate
he was right
or he did know the senate better than
just about anyone else
more importantly he understood why the
work
we were doing mattered
growing up harry's family didn't have
health care
he told me he didn't even know what it
was
harry's brother broke his leg
he stayed in bed and waited for it to
heal
his father needed a tooth removed he
yanked it out himself harry remembered
those times
he knew what that was like
so when harry put everything he had into
passing the aca he didn't do it to
burnish his own legacy he did it for the
people back home and families like
who needed someone looking out for him
when nobody else was
harry got things done
and here's another thing that set harry
apart
he was always
unfailingly
himself
that may not sound exceptional but in
washington it is an exceedingly rare
quality
harry was the first to admit he wasn't
the most charismatic
or politically correct speaker
after a press conference he'd sometimes
go up to a staffer and say
okay
tell me everything i did wrong
but harry knew who he was
and he had the distinct advantage of not
really caring what other people thought
of him
in a town obsessed with appearances
harry had a real vanity deficit
he didn't like phonies
he didn't like grandstanding
he was proud of the fact he didn't own a
tuxedo
when he had to go to fundraisers
he would try to get out in under 10
minutes
and apparently the only white house
congressional picnic harry ever attended
was for his son keys benefit
he wanted to impress a girl
he was dating at the time
he and
miley
ended up getting married so harry
grudgingly admitted it was worth the
sacrifice
finally
for all of harry's toughness
all his hard-nosed views about politics
harry loved his family
loved his staff
and harry was a true and loyal friend
during my time in the senate he was more
generous to me than i had any right to
expect
he was one of the first people that
encouraged me to run for president
believing that despite my youth despite
my inexperience
despite
the fact that i was african-american
i could actually win
which at the time made one of us
you wanted harry and the foxhole with
you
his willingness to fight by my side
to stick with me even when things
weren't going our way
and my poll numbers had
gone down and some democrats thought it
might be prudent to maintain a healthy
distance from me
his willingness to be there
and fight
would last throughout my presidency
it's a debt to him that i could never
fully repay
i remember
toward the end of my time in the white
house michelle and i invited harry and
landra over
for dinner along with joe and jill and
nancy and paul chuck and iris
and during the meal harry was as usual
for muggingly self
occasionally he'd offer an opinion on
this or that
mutter about
the food was pretty good
um
but generally
he was keeping his own counsel
but at the end of the night
those who who were there i suspect will
remember this i sure do
harry suddenly
asked for everyone's attention
listen
he said
everybody here knows that i don't show a
lot of emotion okay
that's just how i grew up
i just want to say that i'm really proud
of what i've done with this president
and i love this guy
and then
without any
warning he leaned over
and kissed me on the cheek
i think it's fair to say that we were
all surprised
and i laughed
i said well
thanks harry
i love you too man
and i put my arm around him
which i think was too much for him
because he said well okay then
it's past my bedtime and with that he
and laundra
headed for the door
pragmatism
adaptability
a premium on getting things done
a lack of pretension
and abiding loyalty
that's what harry reid represented
a man of
old school vergers
they are qualities that are in short
supply these days
and yet it seems to me they are
precisely the qualities
our democracy requires
harry understood we don't have to see
eye to eye on
in order to live together
and be decent toward each other
and that we can
learn to bridge
differences
of background and race and region
he knew that our system of government
isn't based on demanding that
everybody think exactly the same way in
fact it presumes that in a country as
big and diverse as ours people rarely
will
we can still
work together
harry may have been a proud democratic
partisan
he didn't shy away from bare-knuckle
politics but
what is true is
that i never heard harry
speak of politics as if it was some
unbending battle between good and evil
because he knew
what was true for
himself was true for everybody that
we're all a bundle of contradictions
we all have our flaws we all have our
blind spots
but despite all that
it was possible for us to affirm our
collective humanity
because that's what made america great
once we had both left office
i didn't see much of harry
but we'd call each other on the phone
from time to time
and he'd tell me about landra
and he'd speak with great pride about
his kids his grandkids and all that they
were doing
he told me about his illness
and the treatments he was going through
and
what was keeping him busy
and at some point during those calls
he'd usually mentioned somebody he'd run
into who had
thanked him for getting them health care
or save
their job
and
particularly in
recent months maybe knowing that he
didn't have much time left
he'd allow himself a hint of nostalgia
and talk about how
together we've made a darn good team
we've done pretty well for the american
people
as i would start to reply
yes he would cut me off
okay then mr president he'd say and hang
up
the whole conversation would last about
five minutes
but in those five minutes
he'd communicate more
than some folks
do in a couple hours
that's who harry was
a man who knew what was important
and didn't believe in dwelling on one
wasn't
one former colleague explained it by
saying to harry
goodbye was an unnecessary word
it might not have been necessary for
harry
but it is for us
goodbye harry
thank you
for everything
nevada has never had a greater champion
the senate and the country benefited
from your extraordinary leadership
and i could not have asked for a better
truer friend
i sure did love you back